WELL GOOD AFTERNOON I LIKE.
TO CALL THIS MEETING TO ORDER.
I WANT TO START BY THANKING
EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE TODAY
HOW WE HAVE ONLY ONE ITEM ON THE
AGENDA AND THAT IS OUR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
ON PRIVACY.
EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY FIVE ARE
TODAY'S HEARING IS SO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL ODD THAT
REPRESENTS AN AGREEMENT REACHED
WITH THE PROPONENTS OF A
NOVEMBER BALLOT INITIATIVE ON
PRIVACY.
ARM IN ORDER TO WITHDRAW THE
INITIATIVE FROM THE BALLOT ALL
AB THREE SEVENTY FIVE WOULD TELL.
HAVE TO BE SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR BY FIVE PM ON JUNE
TWENTY EIGHTH WHICH IS TOMORROW
AND BECAUSE OF THE SEVENTY TWO
HOUR RULE UNDER PROP FIFTY FOUR
PASSED IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE BILL CAN ONLY
BE HURT DOT TOMORROW ON THE
SENATE FLOOR AT ABOUT TEN THIRTY
IN THE MORNING.
ARE AND SINCE THE BILL IS
CURRENTLY IN THE SENATE ARE THIS
COMMITTEE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
VOTE ON THIS A BILL TODAY.
ARM AND AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL I WILL BE PRESENTING THE
BILL -- AND
I'M GONNA HAND THE GAVEL OVER TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARE KEVIN MULLIN
VERY SHORTLY.
AND OUT THE WAY THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE DOING IT IS THAT --
I WILL BE PRESENTING THEN I'M
GONNA ARE HANDED OVER TO MY A
JOINT AUTHORED AND CO AUTHOR OF
SENATORS THE HERTZBERG AND
SENATOR DOT.
AFTER THEY PRESENTED AND WILL
TURN IT OVER TO THE THREE
WITNESSES HERE.
EACH SIDE WILL HAVE TEN MINUTES
AND HOWEVER DO YOU WANT TO
DIVIDE UP TO TIME SO WE'LL GO
WITH THAT PROPONENTS PROPONENTS
OF THE BILL FIRST AND THEN
FOLLOW UP.
BY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN SOME
OF THE BILL ARE.
SELF TELL US YOUR NAME AND THEN --
YOU KNOW YOUR POSITION AND
THEY'LL GO TO THE OPPOSITION ARE
AND WE'LL INVITE OUR OPPONENTS
COME UP SO WITH THAT.
I'M GONNA HOUSE SO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN TO COME OVER HERE.
TO CHAIRED THE MEETING PRESS THE
MEANING AND AND I'M GONNA GO
.
OKAY MISTER CHAIR.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS TO PRESENT ON
AB
.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH WHO IS CHAIRING THIS.
THERE ARE NO HIGH PURPOSE S. ALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YEAH.
THANK YOU AGAIN.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
WHO WILL BE ARRIVING SHORTLY?
AB THREE SEVEN FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
AS A SIMPLE BILL.
IT IS BASED ON THE PRINCIPLE
THAT PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO CONTROL OF THEIR OWN
PERSONAL DATA.
AND SHOULD NOT BE DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST FOR EXERCISING THAT
RIGHT.
IF THE BUSINESS WANTS TO COLLECT
INFORMATION ABOUT YOU WHILE
YOU'RE SURFING THE WEB.
THEN USE IT FOR REASONS OF THEIR
LIKE PROVIDING A SERVICE.
WAS SELLING IT THEY SHOULD ASK
YOUR PERMISSION FIRST IT IS YOUR
DATA.
YOUR PRIVACY YOUR CHOICE THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE BECAUSE
ONLINE BUSINESSES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO KNOW A GREAT DEAL.
ABOUT A PERSON'S ONLINE
ACTIVITIES IN FACT HEARING FIRST
HAND HOW MUCH.
SOME OF THESE COMPANIES KNOW
ABOUT A PERSON IS WHAT PROMPTED
MR ALISTAIR MCTAGGART TO BECOME
A PRIVACY ADVOCATE.
AND LET HIM AND OTHERS TO PURSUE
A BALLOT INITIATIVE IN THE HOPE
OF CURBING THESE PRIVACY ABUSES
BY GIVING CONSUMERS MORE CONTROL
OVER THEIR DATA.
AND IS WHAT ULTIMATELY LED TO
THE DRAFTING OF THIS BILL BEFORE
YOU TODAY.
MR MCTAGGART IS NOT ALONE IN THE
DESIRE FOR CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE
MORE CONTROL OVER THEIR
INFORMATION.
IN FACT A STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE
PEW RESEARCH CENTER IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN FOUND THAT SOME 74% OF
THE PEOPLE SURVEYED.
SAY THAT IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
THEM THAT THEY BE IN CONTROL OF
WHO CAN GET THE INFORMATION
ABOUT THEM.
THE SAME STUDY FOUND THAT 64% OF
AMERICANS BELIEVE THAT THE
GOVERNMENT SHOULD DO MORE TO
REGULATE WHAT ADVERTISES DO WITH
THEIR PERSONAL INFORMATION.
THIS BILL AB THREE SEVEN FIVE
GIVES CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
GREATER RIGHTS TO EXERCISE
CONTROL OVER DE PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
AND PROVIDES REASONABLE
CERTAINTY.
THAT THERE ARE SAFEGUARDS IN
PLACE TO PROTECT AGAINST DATA
MISUSED.
CIVIC PLAYED GIVES CONSUMERS THE
RIGHT TO REQUESTED A BUSINESS.
CLOSE THE FOLLOWING FIRST THE
TYPE OF PERSONAL INFORMATION
THAT WE COLLECT STORE SELLS
ABOUT THE CONSUMER. TO THE
BUSINESS PURPOSES FOR COLLECTING
WERE SELLING THE INFORMATION AND
THREE THE CATEGORIES OR AYE
IDENTITIES OF THIRD PARTIES WITH
WHOM.
THE INFORMATION IS SHARED SOLD
OR DISCLOSED.
IT ALSO GIVES CONSUMERS TO WRITE
TO REQUESTED A BUSINESS DELETE
ANY PERSONAL INFORMATION
COLLECTED ABOUT THEM AND
REQUIRES BUSINESSES TO DIRECT
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO DO THE SAME.
AB THREE SEVEN FIVE ALSO ALIGNS
ITSELF WITH THE PROPOSED BALLOT
INITIATIVE BY GIVING CONSUMERS
TO RIGHT TO OPT OUT.
OF THE SALE OF THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION WHILE REQUIRING
AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT.
SELL THE PERSONAL INFORMATION OF
CHILDREN UP TO THE AGE OF
SIXTEEN IT ALSO ENSURES EQUAL
RIGHT TO SERVICE MEANING
COMPANIES CANNOT DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST PROVIDING SERVICES. TO
PEOPLE IF THEY DO NOT WANT THEIR
DATA SO.
THE IDEA THAT A PERSON SHOULD
HAVE SOME SAY ABOUT HOW THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION.
THIS CONSISTENT WITH THE RIGHT
OF PRIVACY AND TRYING YOU KNOW
CONSTITUTION.
AND WE AS LEGISLATORS ALSO HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO ENSURE PRIVACY
RIGHTS FOR ONLINE CONSUMERS.
THE AGREEMENT REACHED WITH THE
IN MISSION A PROPONENTS TO MOVE
FORWARD.
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL IS
A SIGNIFICANT STEP.
IN PROVIDING CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS MORE CONTROL OVER
THEIR DATA.
SO AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE --
TO TURN IT OVER TO POP MY JOINT
AND CO AUTHORS SO FIRST OF ALL
SENATOR HERTZBERG AND THEN
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR ALL DOT FOR
SOME BRIEF LA [inaudible]
REMARKS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THE RIGHT TO ACCESS PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
THE RIGHT TO DELETE XIN OF
PERSONAL INFORMATION.
THE RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT PERSONAL
INFORMATION IS BEING COLLECTED.
THE RIGHT TO KNOW WHETHER
PERSONAL INFORMATION IS SOLD OR
DISCLOSED.
THE RIGHT TO SAY NO.
SALE OF PERSONAL INFORMATION.
THE RIGHT TO EQUAL SERVICE AND
PRICE.
ENFORCEMENT BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ENFORCEMENT BY CONSUMERS.
THAT IS THIS MEASURE IN LARGE
PART.
AS I MENTIONED YESTERDAY BEFORE
THE SENATE [inaudible]
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
THE WORLD AND HOW WE SEE IT.
AS BEEN CHANGED IN SO MANY
WONDERFUL INCREDIBLE WAYS BY THE
MAGIC OF THE INTERNET.
BUT THE TECHNOLOGY GENIUS OF SO
MANY.
HAS MET SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
THAT WE NOW TRY TO DEAL WITH IN
THIS LEGISLATION OTHERS AROUND
THE GLOBE OF SOUGHT TO DEAL WITH.
BECAUSE THE TECHNOLOGY OF THE
IDEAS THAT ARE OUT OF THE
CONTRACT YOU AND LEARN THINGS
ABOUT YOU ON THE ONE HAND THAT
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
EXTRAORDINARY SERVICE.
BY THE COMMERCIAL INDUSTRY
PROVIDES INFORMATION ACCESS THE
PEOPLE ON HEARD OF IN HUMAN
HISTORY.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THEY CREATE
CHALLENGES THE ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT.
OFTEN WHEN THOSE KINDS OF
TENSIONS ARE MET IS TO MEDIATE
THOSE CHALLENGES.
HOW WE GOT HERE THROUGH THE
INSPIRATION AND GENIUS OF THE
PERSON WHO CHOSE [inaudible]
TO GET ENGAGED THE FRUSTRATION
THAT'S CAUSED BY SO MANY THAT BR
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT IS A
PROCESS THAT ONE PERSON CAN
LEVERAGE THE PROCESS.
BUT THAT HAS BEEN THE HISTORY OF
DEMOCRACY ALL ALONG.
EXAMPLE AFTER EXAMPLE AROUND THE
GLOBE THERE HAVE BEEN A SMALL
GROUP OF PEOPLE STOOD UP.
THAT IS THE RIGHT TIME IN THE
RIGHT CIRCUMSTANCES THAT GOT
ATTENTION IN ORDER TO SOLVE A
PROBLEM.
SO I THINK THAT AS WE HEAR IN
THIS BUILDING IN THIS BUBBLE
OFTEN GET CONSUMED BY OUR OWN
[inaudible]
IMAGINATION.
THERE'S A LARGER PICTURE OUT
THERE IN TERMS OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO. ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY INDUSTRY HAS THE HESITATION
IS THAT THEY DO WAS OUR SPHERE
OF THAT.
PRECEDENT THAT WILL BE SAID HERE.
CAN BE IT CAN SPREAD ACROSS
OTHER JURISDICTIONS IN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
OTHER STATES.
AND THE RIGHT I THINK IT WILL.
AND I THINK THEIR THEIR RIGHT TO
DO THAT SO WHAT DID WE DO.
WE EXPANDED I THINK I IN A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT WAY WHAT WAS
BUILT ON BY MR MCTAGGART.
EQ YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT THAT
TODAY BECAUSE HE MIGHT HAVE A
CAMPAIGN IF THIS DOESN'T PASS SO
HE'S GOT US DEFEND THE STATUS
QUO.
BUT I'M HOPING THAT HE CHANGED
HIS TUNE.
AFTER THE FACT IN TO EXPRESS HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY AS WE
EVIDENCE TO SENSITIVITY TO SO
MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
RAISED BY IS NOT A TIME I WALK
DOWN THE HALL AT GERMAN HERE
TALKS DOWN THE HALL [inaudible]
DODD.
SAY CAN YOU FIX THIS CAN YOU FIX
THAT.
THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE BEING
ASKED TO FIX OUR SMALL TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THAT RELATE TO
INDUSTRY IN LARGE MEASURE.
WHAT I FIND SO ENCOURAGING IS AT
ALL LEVELS FROM ALL THE BIGGEST
COMPANIES?
THEY GET THEY UNDERSTAND WITH
THIS FUNDAMENTALLY AFFECTS THEIR
CUSTOMER.
THERE OKAY WITH IT BUT THERE'S
SOME ISSUES AS TO THEIR BUSINESS
MODELS OF SOME OTHER ISSUES THAT
PART PROVIDES CHALLENGES QUITE
FRANKLY.
AND THAT'S RIGHT IF WHEN YOU
TALK TO THIS GOOD DID IT DO
DISTRICT COMMITTEE.
IN THE OTHER HOUSE AT NEW JIVE
BUT TALKING TO THEIR FORMER
STAFFER WHO STEPS THIS COMMITTEE
NOW.
IT IS SO MUCH OF WHAT WE DO OVER
THERE IS CORRECT THE LAW WE
DON'T CORRECTED BECAUSE WERE
WRONG WE CORRECTED BECAUSE THE
WORLD CHANGES.
AS I SAID YESTERDAY BRIEFLY THE
NOTION OF THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY
CAME IN THE GRISWOLD CASE IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE COUNCIL.
THAT WHERE --
JUSTICE OR A BILL DOUGLAS CAME
UP WITH THIS NOTION WAS EXTENDED
BY DURAN CHAU WHO WROTE IT INTO
THE CONSTITUTION IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT THOSE WERE BROAD CONCEPTS
TRYING TO EXTEND WHAT THE
CONSTITUTION MET ON THE ONE HAND.
AND THE OTHER HAND AS WE HAVE
THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY CREATES THE
KINDS OF CHALLENGES THAT
GOVERNMENT WAS INTENDED. TO
DESIGN FOR SO I JUST WANNA.
SPIKE THE BUMPS AND BRUISES THE
TEST OF COURSE.
IS MAYBE TO SOME EXTENT HOW WE
GOT HERE.
THOSE REQUIRE A DISCUSSION FOR A
DIFFERENT DAY.
THE BIGGER QUESTION IS TOMORROW.
AFTER THIS LAWS IMPLEMENTED HAVE
WE DONE SOMETHING THAT DOES NOT
HAVE A CHILLING EFFECT AND
INNOVATION ON THE ONE HAND.
AND YET MEETS THE VERY
LEGITIMATE NEEDS OF THE PUBLIC
WITH RESPECT TO WHAT PRIVACY
MEANS ON THE OTHER.
I'M TELLING YOU I THINK IT DOES.
I'M TELLING YOU OVER IN ART FOR
THIS PROCESS WAS THE PRODUCT IS
BY ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE BETTER
THAN THE STATUS QUO.
THAT IN MY JUDGMENT NO
DISRESPECT A PRODUCT BY ORDERS
OF MAGNITUDE IS BETTER THAN WHAT
THE INITIATIVE WAS.
IT WAS INSPIRED BY OUR HONEST
ATTEMPT TO TRY TO DEAL WITH A
VERY DIFFICULT AREA OF THE LAW.
BUT WE FELT THAT THIS PROCESS OF
THE LAST THREE MONTHS HAS
INFORMED THIS IN A WAY THAT IS
GOOD.
I WANT.
TO GIVE ROCKSTAR ACCOLADES TO
THE AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE.
WHO SPENT MANY A MANY A NIGHTS
HIS TEAM ROW SITTING NEXT YEAR
AND MONDO NEVER BLINKED?
MY TEAM OF MICHAEL BUT GUARDED
AND AND FREDDIE WHO WASN'T THERE
AT THAT.
LECH COUNSEL'S OFFICE AT SIX IN
THE MORNING AFTER WE FINISH
DRAFTING AT ONE THIRTY AT THEM
IN THE MORNING TO DO WHAT OFTEN
IS THE IMPOSSIBLE.
CERTAINLY TO TO WHAT MISTER DODD
WHO PROVIDED THE MISSING LINK
AND THE WILLINGNESS TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN WITHOUT MISTER DODD THIS
WOULD NOT BE HERE HERE TODAY.
WELL AND ALSO IF I COULD JUST
SAY TO THE PEOPLE AT THE FRONT
DESKS OF BOTH HOUSES WHO
COMBINATORS KIND OF LAST MINUTE
THING IT'S IMPORTANT.
MR HARRISON'S HERE WHO WAS JUST
AN ELEGANT LAWYER OF BOTH MY
LAWYER AND HAPPENS TO BE MISTER
MCTAGGART SOME LAWYER.
FROM THE GREAT RANCHO FARM.
IN THE BOTH THE PRO TEM STAFF.
AND THE SPEAKER STAFF WHO JUMPED
TO A LOT OF HOOPS TO EVEN ALLOW
US TO BE HERE EVERY APPEARING
EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE DOING.
AT ALL OF THE HOMEWORK AND ALL
OF THE MECHANICS AND THEIR
IMPRIMATUR ON ALL OF THIS WEEK
IS AGAIN.
FOUNDATIONAL TO MAKING THIS
HAPPEN AND SO WITH THAT I JUST
WANT TO SHARE STE CLOSE WITH.
YOU KNOW THE ONE THING THAT THIS
POPOV ACTION GAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE HEART BURN AND WE'RE
GONNA WE'RE WORKING ON WITH THAT
BUT WE THINK WE'VE LIMITED THAT
LANGUAGE IS TO MCTAGGART PUT IN.
A LETTER THAT I THINK EVERYBODY
GOT.
AND LASTLY I PROMISE JUST THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL MISTER HOW THE
OTHER BUS SETTLER.
THAT A I WOULD EXPRESS HIS VIEWS
BECAUSE HE'S WORRIED THAT HE'S A
RIGHTLY TO BE WORRIED WHAT WE'VE
DONE IS WE'VE SET UP A LEGAL
STRUCTURE THAT PUTS GREAT
BURDENS ON HIM.
ON AND IT'S GONNA HAVE TO
REORGANIZE HIS OFFICE AND HAVE
TO GET A LOTTA --
FUNDING TO HIRE MORE LAWYERS IN
THE PRIVACY EXPERTS AND PEOPLE
TO DEAL WITH THE PROCESS THAT
WE'VE SET UP.
AND I TOLD HIM THEN AND I TELL
THIS COMMITTEE THAT IT CHANGE
PROPOSALS IN A BIT ASKING
LEADERSHIP THE SAME THING.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW ORDER TO
GIVE IT MEANING AND I WOULD
PREDICT.
THAT IN FUTURE YEARS BECAUSE OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE TECHNOLOGY
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA AND A
THE ROOM THE ROLE WE'VE GIVEN
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHOEVER THAT MIGHT BE IN THE
FUTURE WILL BECOME BASICALLY THE
CHIEF PRIVACY OFFICER.
AS FOR THE UNITED STATES BECAUSE
OF THE IMPACT THAT THEY WILL
HAVE.
AND WITH THAT AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK THE COAUTHORS OWN THINK
MISTER MCTAGGART WHO.
SLEEPS I THINK LESS THAN I DO
AND THAT'S A HARD THING TO DO.
WITH THAT AND TURNED OVER TO THE
GREAT SENATOR DODD.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND I JUST
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE PRESENCE
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS IRWIN RAY AS
BAKER AND OBERNOLTE WHO JOINED
US FOR THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING
SENATOR DODD THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
I'M VERY VERY PLEASED TO JOIN
WITH US SIMPLY MEMBER CHAO IN
SENATOR HERTZBERG A CO AUTHOR.
THIS CRITICAL PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION BILL.
IT OBVIOUSLY WOULD BE THE
STRONGEST IN THE NATION IN THE
NEXT SAFEGUARDS WE NEED IT IN
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
AT A TIME WHEN FEDERAL
REGULATORS ARE ROLLING BACK
PROTECTIONS WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD HEARING CALIFORNIA.
THIS KNEW BILL INCLUDES
PROVISIONS FROM THE MEASURE I
INTRODUCED EARLIER THIS YEAR SB
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE TO GIVE
CONSUMERS RECOURSE IN THE EVENT
OF FUTURE BREACHES.
PROVIDING A STRONG INCENTIVE FOR
FIRMS [inaudible]
ACT RESPONSIBLY.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO EMPOWER
CONSUMERS INSURING WE ARE
INFORMED ABOUT HOW DATE IS BEING
USED IN GIVING US CONTROL OVER
THE SALE OF OUR DATA.
BIG DATA IS BIG BUSINESS IT'S
TIME THAT WE REGULATED
APPROPRIATELY.
AND HOLD BAD ACTORS ACCOUNTABLE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR A ONE OR
KNOWLEDGE --
WE'VE ENJOYED MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN I BELIEVE NOW WE ARE
GOING TO OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR OTHER INTERESTED PARTIES --
TO COMMENT THAT PROPONENTS OF
THE INITIATIVE OF THAT HAS BEEN
PROPOSED AND THEN THERE WILL BE
OPPORTUNITY I BELIEVE TO OPEN IT
UP FOR A PUBLIC COMMENT AND
QUESTIONS AS WELL FROM THE DAIS.
MISTER MCTAGGART.
TORTURES.
YOU HAVE NEW MY NAME'S ALISTAIR
MCTAGGART AND I'M THE CHAIRMAN
OF CALIFORNIANS FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY.
I AMONG THE PROPOSED THE BALLOT
MEASURE WHICH QUALIFIED MONDAY.
I I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE WHICH DOES IN
OUR OPINION SUBSTANTIALLY AND
MATERIALLY THE SAME THING AS THE
ARE IT A GIVES.
BIG CONSUMERS TRANSPARENCY ABOUT
WHAT COLLECTED CONTROL OVER AYE
WHETHER IT SOLD AND I GIVE THEM
ASSURANCES THAT A BETTER
SECURITY.
I AND IF AB THREE THREE FIVE
PASSES BY TOMORROW AND IS SIGNED
INTO LAW BY THE GOVERNOR.
WE WILL WITHDRAW THE INITIATIVE
ARE DEADLINE TO DO SO IS
TOMORROW AT FIVE I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY THAT IT'S BEEN A ADJOURNING
GETTING HERE --
IT'S BEEN INTERESTING AND I WANT
TO REALLY --
SAY THAT IS WHAT MY EYES TO THE
DEDICATION OF OF THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED THE PROCESS AND I WANT
TO THANK THE THREE THE THREE
GENTLEMAN HERE --
WITHOUT WHOM WE WOULDN'T BE HERE --
I THOUGHT THE PROCESS WAS DEAD
MANY TIMES NAY KEPT ALIVE AND
OUT SO I WANTED THANK GET
SENATOR DODD --
THEATER HERTZBERG AND AND OTHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO --
YOU KNOW WE WERE A ON THE PHONE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAU AND AND AND
THAT HERTZBERG I THINK IT WAS
ACTUALLY LATE AND ONE THIRD
INNINGS BUT TO SAY.
TO OUR ON SUNDAY NIGHT GETTING
THIS THING DONE --
AND YOU KNOW LATIN ABSOLUTE
WOULD NOT HAPPEN ABOUT THE
DEDICATION THEIR STAFFS AND
EDMUNDO --
QUIBUS WHO SAID TO STAFF FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO.
UNLIKE WHAT OUR CHIEF OF STAFF
FOR CENTER HERTZBERG AND GROW
WITHOUT YOUR CREATIVITY.
AND YOUR POURING OIL THROUGH THE
GEARS ARE ON FOOT AND I DON'T
THINK IT'S WE GOT DONE SO THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH NOT RICHARD
OVER TO MY CO WITNESSES WILL
START WITH THE ELITE'S MCDONALD
[inaudible]
A MISTER CHAIR SENATORS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ABOUT CALIFORNIANS PRIVACY DATA.
I AM ALICIA MACDONALD AND I
START NEXT WEEK AS AN ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR AT CARNEGIE MELLON
BASED ARE SILICON VALLEY CAMPUS.
I'M ALSO HERE AS A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR THE
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE.
WHEN I LAST APPEARED BEFORE YOU
IS THE DIRECTOR OF PRIVACY AT
STANFORD CENTER FOR INTERNET AND
SOCIETY WEARING AN AFFILIATED AS
A NON RESIDENT FELLOW?
PRIOR TO STANFORD I WORK FOR
MOZILLA AS A SENIOR PRIVACY
RESEARCHER AND CO CHAIR THE
EFFORTS TO STANDARDIZE THE DO
NOT TRACK WEB BROWSER OPTION
WITHIN THE WORLDWIDE WEB
CONSORTIUM WHICH IS A STANDARDS
BODY.
THE WORK ON DO NOT TRACK HAS
PARALLELS AND LESSONS FOR
CURRENT LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS AS I
WILL TOUCH UPON FURTHER.
BUT FIRST BEING ACADEMIC LET ME
SPEND A MINUTE ON HISTORY.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
INCLUDES THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY AN
ARTICLE ONE SECTION.
ONE ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL
GUIDELINES FOR FAIR INFORMATION
PRACTICE PRINCIPLES OR FIPS.
DEVELOPED IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES IN RESPONSE TO
CONCERNS ABOUT DATA BASES HELD
ON MAINFRAMES.
THESE PRINCIPLES ARE KNOWN AS
NOTICE CHOICE ACCESS SECURITY
AND ENFORCEMENT.
AND THEY'VE BEEN ADOPTED BY THE
FTC THE FCC DHS THE WHITE HOUSE
IS ONLINE CONSUMER BILL OF
RIGHTS.
AND ACROSS MUCH OF EUROPE.
YET THESE BASIC PRINCIPLES OF
THE LAST FORTY FIVE YEARS REMAIN
MOSTLY ASPIRATIONAL.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY
ACT WILL HELP TO REALIZE THE
FAIR INFORMATION PRACTICE
PRINCIPLES.
TECHNOLOGY MOVES QUICKLY WHILE
LAW IS SLOW.
POLICYMAKERS ARE PRUDENTLY
RELUCTANT TO RISK INNOVATION AND
FEAR UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
SO THE FTC PURSUED AN INDUSTRY
SELF REGULATION APPROACH. FOR
INSTANCE THE FTC ENCOURAGE
COMPANIES TO POST PRIVACY
POLICIES.
BUT IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
FTC COMMISSION REPORT AND FOUND
WELL 92% OF WEBSITES COLLECTED
DATA.
ONLY 14% PROVIDED NOTICE OF THE
PRACTICES.
MOST COMPANIES SIMPLY IGNORE THE
FTC'S CALL FOR PRIVACY POLICIES.
THE CALIFORNIA TOOK ACTION AND
PASS THE CALIFORNIA ONLINE
PRIVACY PROTECTION ACT CALL OPA
MAKING CALIFORNIA THE FIRST
STATE TO REQUIRE PRIVACY
POLICIES IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOUR AND THEIR
PRIVACY POLICIES BECAME THE
NATIONAL NORM.
UP BEYOND PRIVACY POLICIES FOR
NOTICE THE FTC ENCOURAGE
INDUSTRY TO BUILD TOOLS TO
OBTAIN THE FULL SET OF
PRINCIPLES.
BUT DURING MY WORK CO CHAIRING
DO NOT TRACK OVER A HUNDRED
POLICYMAKERS ADVOCATES INDUSTRY
LEADERS AND RESEARCHERS WITHIN
THE US AND GLOBALLY.
SPENT YEARS ON SEEMINGLY SMALL
DETAILS.
WE WORKED OUT THE FINER PORT
POINTS OF HOW TO BUILD AN OPT
OUT SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS FOR
PRIVACY YET CAN BE IMPLEMENTED
IN THE REAL WORLD.
THIS BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY
ENCOMPASSES THE LESSONS LEARNED
FROM DO NOT TRACK.
PRIVACY IS NOT SOMETHING AN
INDIVIDUAL COMPANY CAN SOLVE.
WHEN I WORKED FOR MOZILLA WE
WANTED TO RUN AN AD CAMPAIGN FOR
THE FIREFOX WEB BROWSER?
MOZILLA COULD NOT FIND ANY OTHER
BROKERS OFFERING PLACEMENT
WITHOUT TRACKING [inaudible]
NOT.
ONE THERE'S AN INTERLOCKING SET
OF COMPANIES THAT TRANSFER DATA
THAT IDENTIFIES SPECIFIC USERS.
OTHERS IS NO BY NO MEANS AN
INTRACTABLE PROBLEM.
BUT IT IS ONE THAT REQUIRES
COORDINATION.
WORSE CURRENTLY NO COMPANY HAS
THE INCENTIVE TO GO FIRST.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY CUTS
THROUGH THE TWIN PROBLEMS OF
COORDINATION AND INCENTIVES IN A
WAY THAT INDUSTRY SELF
REGULATION STANDARDS BODIES AND
SOFTWARE TOOLS SIMPLY CANNOT
ADDRESS.
SIR HISTORY MENTIONED NOW I
WOULD LIKE TO DISCUSS SUPPORTING
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY
ACT.
WHENEVER THE TEXT OF THE RELATED
PROPOSITION I WAS STRUCK BY HOW
CAREFULLY CRAFTED IT WAS.
AND HOW IT TAKES A REASONABLE
AND FEASIBLE NEXT STEP FORWARD
ON CONSUMER PRIVACY PROTECTIONS.
WITHIN THE PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE WE HAD A CHALLENGE
WE'VE NEVER ENDORSED
PROPOSITIONS.
WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO MAKE UPDATES
TO PROPOSITIONS AND WITH TECH
MOVING SO QUICKLY THE ONE THING
WE KNOW IS CHANGE ABOUNDS.
IN THE END WE ENDORSED ANYWAY
BECAUSE THE PROTECTIONS OFFERED
HER SO RIVER DO.
WE ARE EVEN MORE COMFORTABLE
WITH THE BILL.
IN PARTICULAR OUR ENDORSEMENT IS
BASED UPON CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
GAINING.
THE RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT
INFORMATION A BUSINESSES
COLLECTED ABOUT THEM.
THE RIGHT TO REQUEST THAT
INFORMATION COLLECTED ABOUT THEM
BE DELETED OR PROVIDED IN A WAY
THAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO
TRANSPORT THE DATA.
THE RIGHT TO KNOW WHEN THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION HAS BEEN
SOLD TO THIRD PARTIES TO KNOW
WHAT CATEGORIES OF THIRD PARTIES
THEIR DATA WAS SENT.
TO AND TO OPT OUT OF ANY SALE OF
THEIR INFORMATION TO THIRD
PARTIES.
THE RIGHT OF CALIFORNIANS TO NOT
BE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST IN
SERVICE OR PRICE FOR CHOOSING TO
EXERCISE THEIR PRIVACY RIGHTS.
A LIMITED PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION IN THE EVENT OF A DATA
BREACH.
AND THE CREATION OF FUNDING
MECHANISMS TO ENSURE OF ROBUST
ATTORNEY GENERAL ENFORCEMENT OF
THESE RIGHTS.
THERE WERE ASPECTS OF THE
PROPOSITION THAT WE PREFERRED.
LONG TERM PROSPECT OF
LEGISLATION.
AS RESULT PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE ENDORSED THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
POLICYMAKERS AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO INSURE THAT
THE LAW FULLY PROTECTS
CALIFORNIANS. TO CONCLUDE THE
LOBBY FREE TODAY IS BASED UPON
FORTY FIVE YEARS OF PRIVACY
RIGHTS WORK.
IT DOES NOT SOLVE ALL PRIVACY
ISSUES.
IT IS HOWEVER A VERY GOOD NEXT
STEP AS WE WORK TO EMPOWER
CITIZENS TO PROTECT DEMOCRACY
ITSELF FROM OUT OF CONTROL DATA
YEARS [inaudible]
THE CHAIR.
SENATORS AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME'S ASK CONSUL TONY I'M A
TECHNOLOGIST.
EXPERTS A SPECIALIZING IN
PRIVACY SECURITY AND BEHAVE
ECONOMICS.
OF OVER TWENTY FIVE EXPERIENCE
IN THE FIELD OF SERVICE STOP
TECHNOLOGIES TO THE FTC.
LATER THE CHIEF TECHNOLOGIST THE
FTC OFFICER BRIEFLY EYES A
SENIOR ADVISER TO THE CTO AT THE
WHITE HOUSE OF STP [inaudible]
HARM.
THIS I I ASSISTED THE IN
NUMEROUS STATE AGS ON
ENFORCEMENT INCLUDING CALIFORNIA.
THE PINS ARE PRESENT TODAY
HOWEVER ARE WHOLLY MY OWN IN MY
INDEPENDENT CAPACITY.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING ON SUCH AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
ON AYE PRIVACY AND SECURITY IN
MY OPINION IS THE MOST PRESSING
ISSUE OF OUR DESIRE.
NEARLY FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
CALIFORNIA WAS THE FIRST STATE
TO LEAD IN PROTECTING CONSUMERS
ONLINE BY REQUIRING WEBSITES TO
BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT WHAT
PRIVACY BUT THE PRIVACY
PRACTICES WERE.
WELL AS AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP
WHEN FORGERY SOON REALIZE THAT
MOST CONSUMERS DON'T ACTUALLY
WEEK PRIVACY POLICIES.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY EVEN IF
THEY DID THAT LITTLE CHOICE IN
WHAT THEY CAN DO.
TO IF THEY DISAGREE WITH THE
COMPANY'S PRACTICES DID A MARKET
FAILURE.
THIS MY THE MEASURES TODAY ARE
SO CRITICAL.
LAST FALL I HOPE MR RETARDED
TIGER HAD DROPPED THE COMPANY
CONSUMER PRIVACY BACK ACT THERE
IS ALL INITIATIVE.
AND I'M EXCITED SEE MANY OF
THOSE PROVISIONS WE OUTLINED IN
THAT INITIATIVE ARE INCLUDED IN
AB TWO SEVEN FIVE TODAY.
SPECIFICALLY THE ABILITY FOR
CONSUMERS CONSUMERS TO SEE WHAT
INFORMATION COMPANIES COLLECTED
OR INFERRED ABOUT THEM.
AND GENERALLY WHERE WAS OBTAINED
AND WHOM IT WAS SHARED WITH IS
AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT.
MORE SIGNIFICANT HOWEVER IS THE
ABILITY TO ALLOW CONSUMERS TO
OPT OUT OF THE SALE OF THEIR
DATA SOMETHING THAT CONSUMERS
HAVE OFTEN ASKED FOR BUT HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO.
THE RIGHT TO DELETE DATA
ADDITIONALLY WHEN CONSUMER NO
LONGER WANTS TO USE A SERVICE
WILL ALSO HELP SIGNIFICANTLY IN
REDUCING HARM TO CONSUMERS AND
COMPANIES EXPERIENCE DATA WHICH
NO MORE INSTANCES OF YOUR DATA
BEING.
NOT LEAK FROM A SERVICE YOU HAVE
IN USE IN A DECADE.
THE BILL WOULD OPT OUT INTO THE
ONE SIMPLY HELP PROTECT
CONSUMERS BUT IT'S MY OPINION
THAT WILL SPUR INNOVATION AND
THE WAY COMPANIES MONETIZE THE
SERVICES THEY NOW OFFER.
INCENTIVIZE CLEAN COMES SORRY
INCENTIVIZING COMPANIES WITH
WHOM CHO CONSUMERS HAVE A
TRUSTED RELATIONSHIP WITH. TO
DEVELOP NEW MODELS FOR COMMERCE
WILL ADDRESS THE CORE ISSUES
PLAYING ONLINE ECOSYSTEMS IT IS
FAKE NEWS AND A CAB CAN'T WAS
THIS.
CANNIBALIZATION OF OUR NEWS
AGENCIES.
WE'VE SEEN THE HARMFUL EFFECTS
OF THE OF THE EROSION OF USER
PRIVACY AND CAN NO LONGER SIMPLY
CONTENT OURSELVES WITH IMAGINING
THIS DEBATE HAS A SQUABBLE
BETWEEN PRIVACY ADVOCATES.
AND ONLINE DATA COMPANIES.
THE RULES ON WHAT PRIOR
INFORMATION CAN BE COLLECTED HOW
CAN BE USED AND BY WHOM.
WILL HAVE ENORMOUS IMPACTS ON
THE WELL BEING OF LARGE SWATHS
OF SOCIETY AND INDEED THE
LEGITIMACY AT HEART OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
AN ONLINE DISCOURSE.
AS AN AUTHOR OF THE BOWDEN
INITIATIVE ADVISE ON TODAY'S
BILL I'M STAUNCH IN SUPPORT OF
BOTH.
EACH OTHER STRATS A BENEFITS
WERE BOTH PUT MARK A MAN
MONUMENTAL STEP FORWARD ON LIKE
[inaudible]
SUMA PRIVACY.
SOME OF THE TWENTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE I'M TRULY EXCITED BY
CALIFORNIA'S WILLINGNESS TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND TOOK TO
FURTHER UNDERSTAND THE
COMPLEXITIES MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
TESTIMONY HOW WE ARE GOING TO
HEAR FROM MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC --
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THIS TIME SUPPORTERS OF AB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE IF YOU COULD COME
FORWARD.
OUR STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTED I WOULD
ASK THAT THE COMMENTS UP.
OF REMAIN BRIEF WE HAVE A PRETTY
FULL HEARING ROOM SO NAME
ORGANIZATION AND VERY BRIEF
COMMENTS UP HONEST PERSONAL
PROGRESS CENTER BEFORE YOU START
WITH THE SPORT I I JUST WANNA
ALSO.
I COULDN'T READ MY OWN NOTES
BECAUSE THESE ARE MY REMARKS
RIGHT HERE THE SIZE OF THE BILL.
BUT I I ALSO WANNA GIVE GREAT
CREDIT TO COMMONSENSE IS IN THE
CO SPONSOR OF THIS.
ELIZABETH INCIDENTS SAMANTHA
WORKED HARD AND BROUGH HE WAS
THE FORMER CHIEF DOMESTIC POLICY
ADVISER FOR PRESIDENT CLINTON.
AS WELL AS CHIEF OF STAFF.
TO VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HAS
BEEN VERY INVOLVED IN ALL THESE
MEETINGS HIS WIFE HAD THIS ISSUE
IN TERMS OF FAMILY STUFF THAT HE
HAD TO GO BACK YOU WOULD HAVE
BEEN YOUR OTHERWISE BEHALF
COMMONSENSE I JUST WANTED.
KNOWLEDGE HIS EXTRAORDINARY WORK
EFFORT AS WELL AS THE REST OF
THE TEAM.
THANK YOU CENTER THEY WILL
APPRECIATE THAT SHOT OUT.
AND WHEN I HAD SUPPORTERS OKAY
I'M ELIZABETH POLICE YEAH I'M
VICE PRESIDENT OF COMMON SENSE
KIDS ACTION.
COMMONSENSE YET BUT I'M NOT
NATIONAL NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO
SUPPORTING KIDS AND FAMILIES IN
THE DIGITAL AGE HAS CLOSELY WORK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
OVER THE YEARS TO PROTECT KIDS
PRIVACY.
INCLUDING ON THE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN ERASER BUTTON LA AND
THE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
STUDENT PRIVACY ACTS OF PEOPLE.
KIDS PERSONAL INFORMATION
ACTIVITIES AND NETWORKS ARE
EXPOSED AND OFTEN FOR SALE FROM
BIRTH.
A RECENT NATIONAL POLL FOUND
THAT NINE IN TEN PARENTS AND
TEENS WANT COMPANIES TO PROVIDE
GREATER PRIVACY PROTECTIONS IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON US TO ANSWER
THEIR CALL.
COMMONSENSE IS A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A BILL THAT WERE SECURE
PRIVACY RIGHTS FOR EVERY MEMBER
OF THE FAMILY.
INCLUDING SPECIAL PROTECTIONS
FOR KIDS UNDER SIXTEEN AB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE ALLOWS CONSUMERS TO
MAKE INFORMED CHOICES ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THEIR OWN DATA.
CONTROL THAT FOSTERS HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS WITH TECHNOLOGY
AND OVERALL DIGITAL WELL BEING.
STATE THE PIONEER THE TECH
REVOLUTION SHOULD NOW PIONEER
CONSUMER PRIVACY SAFEGUARDS IF
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE WAY THE
NATION WILL FOLLOW.
WE URGE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO PASS THIS
LANDMARK LEGISLATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS OTHERS TO MAKE THE
CURRENT DAM BEHALF OF CALPERS
WHO UNFORTUNATELY WAS UNABLE TO
YOU I TO JOIN US AT THE HEARING
TODAY BUT DID ASK.
ARTISTS TO SHOW THEIR SUPPORT IF
AMENDED PETITION THEY WANTED TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS IN
ARTICULATING MOST OF THEIR
CONCERNS.
I THROUGH THAT ANALYSIS UP
PERSONALLY I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL
THE AUTHORS MISTER MAKE TIGER
AND THE STAFF HOPEFULLY AFTER
TOMORROW ALL OF US CAN SLEEP.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
URSINE NANCY TRAVEL C. E. O. OF
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M VERY PLEASED TO BE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF WHAT I THINK WILL
BE THAT STRONG BECAUSE CONSUMER
PROTECTION PRIVACY LAW IN THE
NATION --
I'M VERY GRATEFUL TO SENATOR
DODD WHO EARLIER THIS YEAR TOOK
ON THE IMPORTANT ISSUE OF TRADE
TO PREACH.
LIABILITY IN THE WAKE OF THE
EQUIFAX SCANDAL AYE IN THIS BILL
THERE IS A LIMITED BUT WE THINK
WORKABLE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
THAT WILL ALLOW.
CONSUMERS TO RECOVER WHEN THEIR
DATA IS BREACHED IT DOES PROVIDE --
SOME LIMITS SUCH AS THE RIGHT TO
CURE IF A CURE IS POSSIBLE
OBVIOUSLY AN EQUIFAX SITUATION
NO CURE WOULD HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE.
SOMETIMES A CURE MIGHT BE
POSSIBLE IF DATA HAD BEEN
BREACHED TO A PARTNER COMPANY
BUT COULD BE RETRIEVED.
SO WE THINK IT'S A VERY STRONG
CONSUMER PROTECTION LAW.
AND IT'S AN AMAZING
ACCOMPLISHMENT AND I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE SENATOR
HERTZBERG WHO I THINK FOR FIRST
TO HAVE CONFERENCE CALLS AFTER
MIDNIGHT.
AND ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO
WHO IS [inaudible]
AFTER PRIVACY FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OTHER SUPPORTERS.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SCENE NINE A DO WE HAVE
OPPONENTS IN THE ROOM OR THOSE
EXPRESSING CONCERN WITH AB.
THREE SEVEN FIVE AGAIN NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND BRIEF COMMENT
[inaudible]
SORRY [inaudible]
QUICKLY QUICKLY.
THINK WE COULD HAVE OUR
PANELISTS CLEAR OUT AND THE WITH
THE PRIMARY.
OPPONENTS HAVE YOU COME FORWARD
AND HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE
[inaudible]
YEAH RIGHT [inaudible]
AT WE'VE GOT TWO CHAIRS HERE.
WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK YOU?
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MISTER CHAIR SENATORS MEMBERS OF
MY NAME IS SARAH BUT I'M
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF CAL
CHAMBER IN.
OPPOSITION TO AB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE WE APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS BY THE CHAIR AND BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG TO CRAFT A
COMPROMISE LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD AVERT A SIGNIFICANT BALLOT
FIGHT IN NOVEMBER.
OVER THE PRIVACY INITIATIVE
HOWEVER I'M SURE WE CAN ALL
AGREE THIS WHOLE PROCESS HAS
LEFT LITTLE ROOM FOR MEANINGFUL
POLICY NEGOTIATION.
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT
A BILL THAT STANCE IMPACTS
NEARLY EVERY CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
AND CONSUMER.
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY IS VERY
BROAD AND IT'S NOT MONOLITHIC
AND MANY IMPACTED PARTIES HAVE
NOT BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS
PROCESS.
ADDITIONALLY MOST OF US ON THIS
LEGISLATION FOR THE FIRST TIME
I'M ALONG WITH THE REST OF THE
WORLD WHEN IT CAME INTO PRINT ON
THURSDAY.
AND WE WERE TOLD TAKE IT OR
LEAVE IT.
DESPITE THAT NO AMENDMENTS WERE
PUT INTO PRINT MONDAY MORNING
EXPANDING LIABILITY IN WHAT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE DATA BREACH
SECTION OF THIS BILL AND THEY
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH PRIVACY
THEY'RE JUST ADDITIONAL
GIVEAWAYS TO TRIAL ATTORNEYS.
WE HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS OF THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT EXPOSES
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES TO MASSIVE
ADDITIONAL LIABILITY.
AND BASED ON THESE NEW
AMENDMENTS.
THAT LIABILITY WILL PIE
SITUATIONS THAT DO NOT QUALIFY
AS DATA BREACHES UNDER CURRENT
CALIFORNIA LAW.
A LAW THAT IS ALREADY ONE OF THE
MOST AGGRESSIVE IN THE COUNTRY.
MOREOVER THE NEW AMENDMENTS
REMOVED LANGUAGE THAT WOULD HAVE
CARVED OUT SMALLER BUSINESSES
FROM LIABILITY UNDER THE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION ON TOP OF THAT.
THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR SIGNIFICANT
STATUTORY DAMAGES TO BE AWARDED
WITH NO PROOF OF ANY INJURY.
TIME AND AGAIN WE'VE HEARD THAT
IF COMPANIES ARE GOOD ACTORS
THEY WILL NOT BE IMPACTED BY
THIS LAW.
THAT SIMPLY NOT TRUE WITH THIS
LAW MEANS THAT SOON AS THE
COMPANY SUFFERS A DATA BREACH OR
AGAIN WITH THIS LANGUAGE
SOMETHING MORE THEY WILL BE
SLAPPED WITH A LAWSUIT.
AND A WORLD WHERE NO PROOF OF
INJURY IS REQUIRED TO BE ON THE
HOOK FOR HUGE STATUTORY DAMAGES
MANY COMPANIES WILL BE
LEVERAGING TO IMMEDIATE
SETTLEMENT REGARDLESS OF THE
STRENGTH OF THEIR DEFENSE AT
TRIAL. FOR THOSE REASONS SUCH
CAN'T CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HAS
IDENTIFIED SIMILAR LANGUAGE IN
ANOTHER BILL THIS YEAR.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY ONE AS A JOB
KILLER.
YET.
DESPITE HER OBJECTIONS TO THE
MASSIVE INCREASE RELIABILITY OF
THIS BILL AND OTHER PROBLEMS
WITH THE LEGISLATION.
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY ISN'T AN
UNTENABLE SITUATION.
ALTHOUGH EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY
FIVE IS DEEPLY FLAWED THE
PRIVACY INITIATIVE IS MUCH WORSE.
AND THE STAKES ARE ASTRONOMICAL
BECAUSE IF THE INITIATIVE IS
PASSED THE LEGISLATURE WILL BE
VIRTUALLY UNABLE TO AMEND THE
LAW ON THE FUTURE.
THIS IS PROBLEMATIC BOTH BECAUSE
OF THE SIGNIFICANT FLAWS IN THE
INITIATIVE AND BECAUSE WE WOULD
HAVE TO REJECT RETURN TO A VOTE
OF THE PUBLIC IN ORDER TO CHANGE
THE LAW AN AREA WHERE BUSINESSES.
AND TECHNOLOGIES ARE CONSTANTLY
EVOLVING.
THAT WOULD NOT BE A GOOD OUTCOME
FOR ANYONE.
SO AT THIS LATE HOUR WE PREFER
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO THE
INITIATIVE.
THE BUSINESS COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
AND REMAINS DEDICATED TO
CRAFTING REASONABLE PRIVACY
LEGISLATION WE STRONGLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO FIX THE NUMEROUS
PROBLEMS PRESENTED BY THIS BILL
AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THESE INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT
LIMITED.
TO THAT LANGUAGE IN MANY PARTS
OF THE BILL IS CONFUSING IT
COULD BE DIFFICULT FOR
BUSINESSES AND CONSUMERS
UNDERSTAND THAT WILL CERTAINLY
LEAD TO MORE LITIGATION --
I PARTY TOUCH ON SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS WITH THE PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION BUT THERE'S ONE
ADDITIONAL POINT TO BE RAISED
ADAM THE USE OF THE WORDS
UNAUTHORIZED DISCLOSURE LEAVES
OPEN THE POSSIBILITY THAT A
VIOLATION OF OTHER PARTS OF THE
BILL.
COULD BE BROUGHT INTO THIS
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION FOR
EXAMPLE THE CUSTOMER OPTS OUT OF
THIRD PARTY DATA SHARING AND
COMPANY MISTAKENLY SHARES IT
WITH A THIRD PARTY.
ARGUABLY THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED UNAUTHORIZED
DISCLOSURE AND THERE'S NOTHING
IN THE CURRENT LANGUAGE OF THE
BUILT EXPLICITLY PREVENT SUCH AN
INTERPRETATION.
ALTHOUGH STATEMENT WAS MADE IN
YESTERDAY'S HEARING --
AND THERE'S APPARENTLY A LETTER
TO THAT EFFECT THERE'S NO INTENT
TO APPLY THE DATA BREACH PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION THE OTHER PARTS
OF THE BILL --
WE I DON'T RECALL HEARING A
COMMITMENT MADE ON THE RECORD --
TO RESOLVE THAT ISSUE BEFORE THE
LAW -- TAKES
THE FACT AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE.
FINALLY I WANT TO RAISE A FEW OF
THE EXAMPLES OF THE MANY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
BILL.
THAT CONSUMERS WILL NOT
APPRECIATE.
THIS BILL COULD JEOPARDIZE THE
ABILITY OF RETAILERS PROVIDE
LOYALTY AND REWARDS PROGRAMS TO
CUSTOMERS.
IT COULD PREVENT COMPANIES ROTH
ACTUATING PRODUCT SAFETY RECALLS.
IT COULD IMPACT THE THIRD PARTY
SHARING OF DATA FOR FRAUD
PREVENTION AND DETECTION.
AND SOME OF THE DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL COULD
BE READ TO FORCE COMPANIES TO
REDUCE INFORMATION ABOUT ONE
CONSUMER TO ANOTHER.
WHICH GOES AGAINST THE PRIVACY
BECAUSE OF THIS LEGISLATION.
AGAIN THESE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
NUMEROUS PROBLEMS WITH THIS BILL
AND FOR THESE REASONS AND MORE
WE ARE POSED AB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE BUT ULTIMATELY.
WE MAINTAIN A PREFERENCE FOR
THIS LEGISLATION OVER THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE BECAUSE IT IS FAR
WORSE.
THANK YOU MISTER MCKINLEY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU FINANCE KEVIN KELLY
WITH INTERNET DISSOCIATION THIS
BEEN A DIFFICULT PROCESS.
AND WE HAVE MANY SUBSTANTIVE
POLICY CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL.
HOWEVER WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
LEGISLATORS EFFORTS TO TAKE THIS
IMPORTANT COMPLICATED DISCUSSION
WAY FOR THE BALLOT BOX AND BRING
IT IN WARM PART.
APPROPRIATE VENUE OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
AS CAL CHAMBER MENTIONED DATA
REGULATION POLICIES HIGHLY
COMPLEX.
AND IMPACTS NEARLY EVERY SECTOR
OF THE ECONOMY INCLUDING THE
INTERNET INDUSTRY.
IF THE INITIATIVE BECAME LAW THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE VIRTUALLY
UNABLE TO AMEND ITS PROVISIONS
GOING FORWARD.
A DANGEROUS PROSPECT GIVEN HOW
NIMBLE AND RESPONSIVE THE STATE
MUST BE IN ITS POLICIES TO
ENSURE.
WE REMAIN A GLOBAL LEADER
INNOVATION TECHNOLOGY.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE MOVING
FORWARD TO ENSURE THE STATE'S
TECHNOLOGY LEADERSHIP REMAINS A
REALITY.
THING WAS KELLY WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM NEWS
PUBLISHERS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JIM <c.green> WORK FOR THE</c>
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION.
I'M WE'VE ANALYZE THIS BILL I'M
AS IT PERTAINS TO THREE FACETS
OF OUR OPERATION ADVERTISING.
AUDIENCE DEVELOPMENT MORE
COMMONLY KNOWN AS CIRCULATION
AND NEWS GATHERING.
ON WHAT WE DON'T HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON ANY OF THOSE --
AREAS WE DO HAVE VERY
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF THE BILL HONOR NEWS
GATHERING OPERATIONS.
IN PARTICULAR I'M DEALING WITH
THE OPT OUT PROVISION.
AS WE READ THE DEFINITIONS IN
THE BILL OF PERSONAL INFORMATION
OF THE ON SALE SALE OF
INFORMATION.
ON BUSINESSES THAT WOULD BE --
ARE -- PART
OF THE THE PROHIBITION --
WE THINK THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON OUR ABILITY TO COLLECT
INFORMATION ABOUT SIGNIFICANT
EVENTS IN A COMMUNITY.
AS WELL AS TO PUBLISH THAT
INFORMATION EITHER ONLINE OR IN
OUR PRINT PUBLICATIONS.
ARE AN EXAMPLE WOULD BE --
THE GYNECOLOGIST AT USC.
WHERE THAT INFORMATION THAT WAS
OBTAINED WAS MOSTLY FROM PRIVATE
SOURCES IT WASN'T OBTAINED FROM
PUBLIC SOURCES AND IN THE WORK
THAT WAS A LITTLE BIT BUT ARE
MOSTLY FROM PRIVATE SOURCES?
ON THAT STORY IF THE
GYNECOLOGIST GOT WIND OF THE
IMMINENT PUBLICATION OF THE
STORY COULD USE THE OPT OUT
PROVISION IN THIS BILL TO
PREVENT THE PUBLICATION OF THAT
STORY.
COMMUNITIES WOULD LOSE IF THAT
WERE THE CASE.
ANOTHER CONCERN THAT WE HAVE IS
THE POTENTIAL IMPACT OF THE
REQUIREMENT TO DISCLOSE
INFORMATION TO THE CONSUMER HIM
OR HERSELF --
OUR OWN DE LA SHIELD LAW ARE
BECAUSE THEY COULD BE REQUIRED
THAT A NEWSPAPER DISCLOSED
INFORMATION THAT'S ON PUBLISHED
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
PROTECTED UNDER THAT.
A PROVISION WE'VE SHARED OUR
CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHORS.
I'M WITH THE PROPONENT ARM OF
THE BILL.
AND WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
GET THAT ADDRESSED.
THANK YOU FOR HER.
THANK YOU SIR OTHER OPPONENTS OF
AB THREE SEVENTY FIVE IF YOU
COULD QUEUE UP --
BEHIND THE AUDIENCE MICROPHONE
NAME AND ORGANIZATION EVERY
COMMENT.
LARA GLAD STATE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BANKING
NETWORK ON THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BUT WE DO
VIEW IT AS BETTER ALTERNATIVE.
SPECIFICALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
RETAILERS I WOULD LIKE SAY
BRIEFLY THAT --
AS THE TWO AUTHORS ACKNOWLEDGING
THIS BILL WAS LARGELY WRITTEN A
TECH COMPANIES IN MIND FOR
COMPANIES THAT HAVE BEEN IN
EXISTENCE FOR LITERALLY DECADES
COMPLIANCE WITH CONSUMER REQUEST.
A ON THE INFORMATION WE HAVE
THEM WHERE THEY'RE BEEN LEGACY
SYSTEMS MERGERS ACQUISITIONS AND
YOU KNOW A COMPANY QUE CUSTOMER
CONSUMER COULD HAVE BEEN A
CUSTOMER FOR MANY GENERATIONS
AND SO -- WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD AND IS
IMPLEMENTED IT RECOGNIZES THAT --
WHILE THE MAIN FOCUS MAY HAVE
BEEN TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES THERE
ARE OTHERS IN EXISTENCE IS HAS A
DEEP IMPACT ON AND SO WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO TRY AND
WORK WITH US THE AUTHORS ON
THOSE ISSUES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MORE ABOUT IT WITH
TECH NET WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
OF THOSE AND PREVIOUSLY STATED
THAT WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
ATTEMPTS ON THIS POLICY
DISCUSSION AND THAT IT WOULD
MOVES LEGISLATURE WHICH THE
APPROPRIATE VENUE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS KEVIN
GOLD CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION ARE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION.
OUT WE LOOK FOR THE FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND AMENDMENTS
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE ENTITIES
THAT ARE ALREADY COVERED.
UNDER THE FEDERAL.
NOW GRAMM LEACH BLILEY ACT AS
WELL AS CALIFORNIA'S FINANCIAL
INFORMATION PRIVACY ACT THANK
YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS ALL OF IRAQ GRAY
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
FIELDING GRIEVES FOR THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY POST.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOE EN
BETTENCOURT REPRESENTING THE
SECURITIES INDUSTRY.
AND FINANCIAL MARKETS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION A WE
HAVE THE SAME ISSUES AS THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU.
GERMAN BIRTH TRUST BUT THE WITH
THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS AND CONCERNS
REYES ON THE EXCHANGE THAT
PARAGRAPH ACTION AND THAT
CONFLICTS WITH THE SINK
[inaudible]
AS NOW WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT.
THIS MEASURE WILL PROVENCHER
BANG QUORUM EMERGENCY SERVICES
TO OUR POLICYHOLDERS IN
CALIFORNIA --
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE NOSE
VISIONS ARE DRAFTED FOR EXAMPLE
ROADSIDE SERVICES TOWING
SERVICES DEBRIS REMOVAL AFTER
NATURAL CATASTROPHES OR ALL THE
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE THAT.
NUMBER PART WOULD TED DO A
SEARCH REQUIRED TO SHARE
INFORMATION SO IS OUR HOPE THAT
THE AUTHORS AND LEGISLATURE WILL
WORK WITH INSURERS AS TO JUST
ISSUES OF THIS MOVE.
FOR MIMI PETRON WITH Q. CAPTAIN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES.
AYE WE WOULD ASSOCIATE OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER THINKING.
KEVIN ANDERSON A BEHALF OF THE
RETAIL INDUSTRY LEADERS
ASSOCIATION AND ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THINK YOU.
THE AIR MARINO MAP THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION ECHOING
THE SENTIMENTS OF THE PREVIOUS --
A TESTIMONY JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
Y. A ONE POINT FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT MR MCTAGGART SPOKE TO SOME
FOLKS SAYING THAT THIS IS NOT.
MEANT TO AFFECT AWARDS PROGRAM
REWARDS PROGRAM TO SOME OF OUR
STORES RELIANT TO PROVIDE LOW
PRICE STARK CONSUMERS --
WORK LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND AND THE SENATORS TO MAKE
SURE THAT OF THAT IS INDEED THE
CASE AS WE REPORT THIS THINK
THAT MUCH [inaudible]
IF YOU.
COURTNEY JOHNSON OF CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNION LEAGUE IN
OPPOSITION WE HONOR COMMENTS
WITH THE COMPANY BANKERS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS CONTINUED
CONCERN AROUND THAT
DISCRIMINATION SECTION AND THE
BILL THANK YOU.
CAROLINE MCINTYRE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION.
I'M GLAD TO BE HERE TO BE A PART
OF THIS EFFORT AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OTHERS THAT WILL BE INVOLVED.
TO ADDRESS SOME REMAINING ISSUES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL OF A
BRING IT BACK TO MY COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
THOUGHTS FROM THE DAIS
[inaudible]
MISTER OBERNOLTE --
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT
TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE AUTHORS
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD THIS
IS A TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT
TOPIC.
I THINK IT'S AN APPROPRIATE
DISCUSSION FOR US TO BE HAVING
IN A STATE THAT'S THE BIRTHPLACE
OF A LOT OF THE COMPANIES THAT
USE THIS DATA.
AND I THINK WE OUGHT TO BE PART
OF SHAPING PRIVACY POLICY FOR
THE ENTIRE NATION AND MAYBE THE
WORLD FOR OTHER COMING.
BUT I ALSO THINK IT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE FOR US TO BE HAVING
THIS DISCUSSION AS A LEGISLATURE
AND I DEEP CONCERNS WITH THE
INITIATIVE MOVING FORWARD OF MR
MCTAGGART IT'S NICE TO SEE NOT
UNDER LESS ADVERSARIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES.
WE HAD A ROBUST DEBATE ABOUT THE
INITIATIVE.
PA THE INITIATIVES COMMITTEE AT
OUR PARTY CONVENTION.
A I DO HAVE A CONCERN THOUGH
BECAUSE ALTHOUGH IT'S GREAT THAT
WE'RE HAVING THIS DISCUSSION AS
A LEGISLATURE I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE ARE IT'S VERY
ABBREVIATED JUST BECAUSE OF KIND
OF THE ARTIFICIAL DEADLINES
IMPOSED BY.
THE WITHDRAWAL OF THE INITIATIVE
SO ARE.
IT'S IT'S A COMPLEX TOPIC AND I
THINK IF YOU LOOK AT HOW
VOLUMINOUS THE BILL ALREADY IS
IT'S VERY CLEAR.
THAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE A LOT OF
ATTENTION TO DETAIL TO GET THIS
EXACTLY RIGHT SO WE GOT TO
BLATANT IMPLEMENTATION IN HERE
WHICH IS GOOD GIVES US ALL THE
TIME TO WORK THROUGH.
THE ISSUE BUT IF THE AUTHORS TO
TALK.
WHAT THE PROCESS IS GOING TO BE
OVER THE NEXT TWELVE MONTHS TO
IDENTIFY AND SOLVE THE
INEVITABLE IMPLEMENTATION
DETAILS THAT ARE GOING TO ARISE
REFERRED A FEW OF THEM ALREADY?
AND I IF YOU COULD TALK ABOUT.
WHAT THOSE ISSUES ARE AS YOU SEE
THEM WHAT THE PROCESS IS GOING
TO BE TO FIX THEM OTHER COULD BE
HELPFUL?
I'LL BE HAPPY THERE ARM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR QUESTION
LIMIT MANY BEGIN BY.
ADDRESSING ONE OF THE ISSUES
MAJOR ISSUES THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT
UP AND THAT IS THE OF THE
PROCESS ITSELF.
FOR YA TO THE PROCESS BY WHICH
WE CAME TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
AND DOT I. M. THE PULLEY ONE OF
THE FIRST PEOPLE TO ADMIT THAT
ARE YOU KNOW I WISH WE HAD MORE
TIME I THINK THAT IS.
A THAT IS ONE A CONCERN THAT WE
ARE YOU KNOW A LOT PEOPLE HAVE.
ARE OVER JUST PROCESS AND I YET
YOU KNOW IT IS SOMETHING THAT
WILL YOU DATA WE HAVE TO ABIDE
BY ESSENTIALLY TO IN TWENTY
EIGHT IS THAT THE AIRLINE.
SO WE REALLY DO NOT HAVE A LOT
OF TIME TO TO DO THIS A VERY
IMPORTANT WORK.
YET I THINK GOD WHEN I BEGAN --
INVOLVING MYSELF IN IN THIS
PROCESS AND I THINK IT WAS BACK
IN APRIL OF TIME FRAME.
ARE A EN WOULD DO TO THE WAY
THAT WE APPROACH THIS WASTE THAT
WE REACHED OUT TO AS MANY
STAKEHOLDERS AS POSSIBLE. TO
SOLICIT INPUT AND FEEDBACK FROM
THEM ARE BASICALLY REQUESTING
THEM TO PROVIDE US WITH ARMED
YOU KNOW --
SOLUTIONS ARE AYE.
WELL FOR EXAMPLE ARE THAT THEY
COULD DOUBT PROVIDE TO US AND WE
DID HAVE A NUMEROUS MEETINGS
OVER THE YOU KNOW THE THE SPAN
OF MAYBE TWO TO THREE WEEKS TO
SELL.
REACHED OUT TO THE ALL THE
COMMUNITIES THE TECH INDUSTRY
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY ARE ARE
THE CONSUMER PRIVACY FOLKS AND I
KNOW I AND WE EXTENDED THE SAME.
ARM IMITATION TO THEM AND BASED
ON THEIR INPUT AND BASED ON THE
OUR CONTENT OF THE INITIATIVE
WHICH IS WHAT WE BASICALLY USED
TO TO PROVIDE A FRAMEWORK FOR
DRAFTING THE LANGUAGE.
WE ARE AS A RESULT TRAFFIC THE
TO LANGUAGE AND THAT THE
LANGUAGE CHAU WENT THROUGH A
NUMBER OF ITERATIONS ARE AND
ALSO INVOLVED A THE HOLDERS IN
DRAFTING THE LANGUAGE AND THAT'S
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE.
ARE CAME UP WITH COME UP WITH
OVER THE SPAN OF FOR SEVERAL
WEEKS SURE DON'T PLEASE DON'T
INTERPRET THE QUESTION IS
CRITICISM I THINK YEAH I JUST
HAPPEN I WANT TO TWO MONUMENTAL
JOB YET JUST IMPOSSIBLE. TO WORK
THROUGH AN ISSUE THIS COMPLEX IN
SO SHORT A PROCESS YEAH AND SO I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAD A
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT THE
PROCESS IS GOING TO BE HAVE
SELECTED TO IRON OUT THE DID THE
YOU KNOW THE DEFICIENCIES YEAH
SO.
NOW TO YOUR QUESTION AND YOU
KNOW WHAT IS WHAT ARE WE CAN
EXPECT A IN THE IN THE COMING
MONTHS OR COMING WHATEVER CASE
IT MAY BE.
AND MY COMMITMENT IS TO ON THEIR
LOOK AT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THESE ISSUES AND AND SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO.
I AND I THINK YOU MENTIONED
CORRECTLY THERE IS A ONE YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION DELAY ARE.
YOU KNOW HOW BY WHICH WE COULD
USE TO I'VE BEEN UP BROUGHT TO
OUR ATTENTION.
AND OUR ALLY EN DA IF OF THESE
ISSUES ON MERIT THEY ARE --
YOU KNOW --
LOOKING AT MORE CLOSELY WOULD
DEFINITELY DO THAT A WE DO NOT
ONE THAT'S SAFE WHO DO NOT WANT
E. G. ARE GETTING CONFUSED FOR
EXAMPLE I MEAN THAT'S ONE
EXAMPLE --
IF THE AGE YOU CANNOT EVEN
ENFORCED AND WE WILL WE WANT DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT SO THAT'S ONE
EXAMPLE THAT WE WANNA.
I WANNA COMMIT MYSELF TO WORKING
AND OUT.
AND ALL THAT MY OUR COLLEAGUES
TO SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES BUT BUT
I THINK.
OUR YOU KNOW WE HEARD TODAY
WE'VE HEARD A NUMBER OF
POTENTIAL ISSUES THAT'S BEEN
RAISED AND I HAVE TO LOOK AT
EACH ONE OF THEM OTHER CAREFULLY
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY TO
MARIETTA.
IN FURTHER --
RESEARCHER FOR THEIR HA A REMEDY.
IF I CAN GET A BIT TO THAT IS
OKAY MISTER [inaudible]
CHAIRMAN CLICK ON ACTING GET YOU
KNOW LOOK AT YOU RIGHT IT'S IT'S
IT'S SOMEWHAT CHALLENGING ON AND
IT WOULD BE NICE IF WE COULD
HAVE DONE IT SOONER WAY I'D
WORKED VERY HEAVILY ON THIS
PROCESS TO CREATED IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
AND WANTED TO GET --
HEARINGS DONE WAS HIT WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS AFTER 25% KNOWS
WHICH THEN WOULD HAVE.
MOVE THIS FORWARD.
THIS VERY HUMAN ANSWER TO THIS.
FIRST OF THE GIVEN THE THOUGHT
WE'RE GOING TO GET SOMETHING
DONE.
I JUST DON'T THINK ANYBODY
THOUGHT IT WAS POSSIBLE.
AND I DON'T THINK THERE WAS REAL
SERIOUSNESS OF PURPOSE BECAUSE
OF THAT [inaudible] TO THE
NATURE OF ADVOCATES OF WHICH I
AS A LAWYER M..
EAST ARGUE FEW YOUR INTERESTS.
AND SO WHAT WE SAW AS WE
CONTINUALLY WERE FRUSTRATED
ASKING EVERYBODY UNDER THE SUN
GIVE IMPORTS WE HAD ADVOCACY.
WOULDN'T GET SOLUTIONS WE CAN
GET COMPROMISE.
PARTLY BECAUSE IT THINK IT WAS
IN THE GET DONE AND PARTLY
BECAUSE OF THAT INCIDENT BURKE
AT THE CLOCK.
IT IMPOSED UPON US WE FELT THAT
NO MORAL OBLIGATION TO INCLUDE
AS MANY [inaudible]
WE COULD.
I THINK IT WAS SAID HERE'S THAT
WOULD LOBBY GROUPS THAT PROBABLY
DIDN'T EVEN THINK OF THEMSELVES
AS PART OF THIS DISCUSSION
BECAUSE IT WAS GENERALLY.
ARM.
A A COUCH IN THE FORM OF TECH.
AND THERE ISN'T MUCH BROADER
AFFECT WE LOOKED AT THE
RETAILERS OR AS A LOT OF A A
FOCUSES SMALLER BUSINESSES NOW
THE TWENTY FIVE MADE ARE CUT OFF
BUT STILL SOMEONE COULD BE.
IN A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
WHATEVER NOT HAVE THE LEVEL OF
TECHNOLOGICAL SOPHISTICATION SO
IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE SOME
HOMEWORK THERE.
SO WHAT WE DID WAS IS
RESPONSIBLE LEGISLATORS TRYING
TO BALANCE OUT THIS CHALLENGE.
ON ON THE ONE HAND ARE AND ON
THE OTHER HAND TRY TO REALIZE
THAT THERE WOULD BE LEGITIMATE
ISSUES THERE ALWAYS ARE MENTION
MY OPENING COMMENTS.
CAN'T TELL YOU KNOW THE BEERS
HAVE BEEN AROUND THIS PLACE HALF
THE STUFF YOU DO IS CORRECT
MISTAKES THAT YOU FROM BEFORE OR
THIS NEW KNOWLEDGE THAT COMES
FROM ADVANCEMENT OR WHATEVER NEW
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IN I REMEMBER WHEN MERCED THEIR
GRAPPLING WITH WHAT WE DO WITH
FAX MACHINES CAN WE TAKE A FACT
SIGNATURE AND HOW DO YOU GET
PAST THAT WHAT SIGNATURE ON A
DOCUMENT.
THINGS THAT TODAY WE TAKE FOR
GRANTED AND YET YEARS AGO THEY
WERE HUGE ISSUES ABOUT WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE IT HOW WE
AUTHENTICATE DOCUMENTS AND ALL
THAT STUFF.
SCOOBY ADVANCEMENT OF THING OF
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN LIFE
AND LAW.
YOU KNOW OUR OUT OF WOOD HOMES
TALKED ABOUT THE LIFE OF THE LAW
HAS BEEN LOGIC IT'S BEEN
EXPERIENCING WHAT WE'RE SEEING
HERE TODAY.
IS EXPERTS I THINK WHAT YOU'LL
SEE IS THERE WASN'T THERE WAS A
BIG QUESTION BY.
THE LARGER COALITION OF FOLKS
THAT SAY.
THE LETTER AND I DID IF I NUMBER
OF ISSUES THAT BEAR SOME.
WOULD YOU AGREE TO A PROCESS AND
THE CHAIRMAN SAID HE WOULD I'M
CERTAINLY TALK TO A NUMBER OF
FOLKS I TALKED TO THE AG ABOUT
FUNDING AND OTHERS.
AND I THINK WILL YOU KNOW IT WE
HAVEN'T CONFIRMED ANYTHING WITH
THE LEADERSHIP YET BUT THE IDEA
WOULD BE CLEARLY THERE'S GONNA
BE CLEAN UP BILLS.
ITS PRIVACY CHAIRMAN.
WE'LL PROBABLY DO.
A B. THREE SEVENTY SIX AND AND
AND THEN WILL YOU HAVE THE
NORMAL LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THAT
WE HAVE THE ENTIRE YEAR. TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
BUT GIVEN THE URGENCY OF A KNOW
YOU RESPECT THAT I JUST WANT TO
PUT IN THE RECORD.
THAT AND WE'LL FIGURE THAT OUT
AND MR MATTEL YOU'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK FREE FOR ANOTHER YEAR.
WELL THANK YOU I'M I'M ARE.
VERY GLAD THAT THERE'S A
COMMITMENT TO SOLVING THOSE
PROBLEMS MOVING FORWARD AND I
THINK IF YOU WANT EVIDENCE OF
THE CAREFUL JOB THAT YOU'VE DONE
IN CRAFTING THE BILL IN THE
SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME.
THAT YOU HAD.
ALL ONE HAS TO DO IS LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE LANGUAGE
IN THE INITIATIVE WHICH IS JUST
A COUPLE PAGES LONG.
AND THE LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL
WHICH IS TWENTY THIRTY PAGES
LONG TO SEE YOU KNOW ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT HOW A HURDLES THAT
YOU'VE HAD TO OVERCOME SO.
I COMMEND YOU FOR THAT ARE. ONE
THING THAT I'M THE MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT I REALLY
HOPE THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS IN THE
EIGHT NEXT EIGHTEEN MONTHS
BEFORE THE IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THIS BILL THERE IS THAT WE
DON'T EXPAND THE PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION IN THIS BILL TO DATA
BREACHES THAT ARE UNRELATED TO
THE PRIVACY CONCERNS OF THE BILL.
OUR THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU
HEARD THAT THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE REYES IT'S A CONCERN
THAT I HAVE AS WELL SO I'M VERY
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN WORK ON THAT
MOVING FORWARD BUT I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR HARD WORK
ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU MISS OBERNOLTE.
THIS BAKER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THAT HARD WORK A LOT OF
SAUSAGE GETS MADE UP HER.
AND WHILE SAUSAGE.
IT IS GREAT THAT THE CONTENTS
CAN SOMETIMES BE REALLY BAD AND
ONE OF THE THINGS I HOPE WE WILL
LOOK FOR IS WHAT AND SAID I'M
HEARING A VERY AUTHENTIC
COMMITMENT IS TO FIX SOME OF
THOSE.
PROVISIONS THAT ONCE THAT I AM I
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE AND HOPE
THAT THERE CAN BE AN AGREEMENT
TO DO.
INCLUDES THE REFERENCES MY
COLLEAGUES MADE TO THE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION THAT CAN MAKE.
WELL INTENTIONED LEGISLATION
COST SO MUCH EXPONENTIALLY MORE
AND HAVE REALLY BAD CONSEQUENCES --
AND SO I AYE ECHO THAT.
THE OTHER HAS TO DO WITH THE M.
NEWSPAPER PUBLICATION COMMENT.
THAT IS A CONCERN A AS WE HAVE
NEW TECHNOLOGY WE ALSO HAVE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES. TO BE VICTIMS AS
WELL AS TO BE PROTECTED AND THE
PARTICULAR EXAMPLE THAT WAS
RAISED IS NOT WHAT I HEARD
BEFORE IT DOES ADAM.
BECAUSE CONCERNED ABOUT HOW.
A WE MAY HAVE.
A A PROBLEM OF FINDING OUT HOW
THOSE YOU CAN CAUSE CRIME ME NO
I DON'T SEE A RECOGNIZED FACE OF
SAY SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION OF
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION OR
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT MAY
ALSO BE PART OF UNDERSTANDING
WHAT WE DO WITH DATA BUT I
WONDER IF YOU CAN COMMENT.
ON THAT WHEN I HAVE ONE MORE
AFTER THAT.
ON SHARE ARE WHO WE ARE MINDFUL
OF OF EVERYONE WHEN WE DRAFTED
THE THE LANGUAGE INTO.
A WHICH IS THE REASON WHY WE
INSERTED INTO A LANGUAGE THAT --
LITTLE SECTION RECORDING FIRST
AMENDMENTS HER AND IN FACT IT IS
STATED IN THE SECTION SEVENTEEN
NINETY ONE POINT ONE OF FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR AND TELL.
SU A WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT THAT
SECTION WITHOUT LANGUAGE WILL
ADDRESS OF THE CONCERN RAISED BY
THE GENTLEMEN.
ARE AND ARE SO.
IF I COULD TELL.
AND THERE'S ALSO ON REFERENCE TO
FOR EXAMPLE.
OUR DISA HAS TO DO WITH THE
DELETION CONTACTS IN AND OUT THE
IT PERTAINS TO EXERCISING OF
FREE SPEECH HERE.
WILL WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
RIGHT OF ANOTHER KIND CONSUMER
FOR EXAMPLE TO EXERCISE HIS.
OR HER OF FREEDOM OF SPEECH A TO
BE PROTECTED BY A VITAL LAW SO
AS YOU CAN SEE WE ARE MINDFUL WE
ARE WHEN WE DRAFTED THE LANGUAGE
WE WE WANTED TO COVER.
MANY OF THESE ARE POTENTIAL
ISSUES SO SO.
ARE YOU KNOW I I YOU KNOW I
GUESS SAID I DON'T KNOW OF THIS
PARTICULAR A PROVISION WILL
ADDRESS THAT GENTLEMAN'S CONCERN
BUT BUT WE THINK IT DOES STATE
THAT WILL YA WILL LOOK AT IT
MORE CLOSELY TO GO AND I BECAUSE
I THINK THAT'S WHERE.
THAT'S WORTHWHILE TO AS YOUR TO
YOU MAY BE ABLE TO DO WITH --
GIVEN THAT WHAT THE PROCESS HAS
BEEN YOU'VE BEEN VERY OPEN WHICH
IS GOOD --
TO THAT CONVERSATION I HOPE THAT
PARTICULAR MINE CAN BE INCLUDED
AS WELL.
AND THE OTHER IS GIVEN THAT --
WE WE ARE IN THE PROCESS WERE
AND WE'RE GONNA FIND WHETHER
IT'S CLEAN UP OR OTHERWISE NEEDS
THAT.
BUT WHAT IF YOU WOULD BE GAME
FOR THERE BEING AN ADDITIONAL.
INFORMATIONAL HEARING PERHAPS
BEFORE FULL IMPLEMENTATION TO
REALLY AIR OUT PUBLICLY ANY
OTHER ADDITIONAL CONCERNS EVER
LOOKING OUT THE POSSIBILITY --
OF LEARNING SOME THINGS EVEN
RIGHT AFTER THIS COULD
POTENTIALLY BE SIGNED.
AND I THINK THAT WOULD BE
FRUITFUL GIVEN HOW THIS PROCESS
HAS BEEN SO ABBREVIATED --
TO DO THAT I DIDN'T ASK YOU
BEFORE THE HEARING WOULD BE
HAPPY TO BUT IF IF THAT'S OF
SOMETHING YOU WOULD PLEASE
CONSIDER.
THERE BE ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITY
AIR OUT IN MORE DETAIL --
WITHIN A YEAR WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT EVEN THE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION FULLY KICKS AND I
I THINK THAT WOULD BE VERY GOOD
TO DO --
BRINGING MORE LIGHT TO THE
PROCESS AND SEE YOU BEFORE.
AND FOLKS START FACING MORE
LIABILITY WHAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO DO AYE I HOPE WE CAN
ENCOURAGE OUT I'D BE SURPRISED
IF.
BOTH BODIES WHEN BE WILLING TO
DO IT I THINK YOU FOR IT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUGGESTION
WE'LL CHECK IN WITH THE REST OF
THE TEAM THANK.
THANK YOU AS BAKER WE'VE BEEN
JOINED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE SIR AND I
KNOW THAT MR BERMAN HAS A
QUESTION OR COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
AND JUST TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
OF MY COLLEAGUES IN ONE I THINK --
THE SANDERS AND AND CHURCH OUT
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE -- ON
THIS AND AND YOUR STAFF'S THIS
POINT --
THINK THE SPONSOR OF THE
INITIATIVE FOR BEING WILLING A
WANNA HIT THE PAUSE BUTTON ON ON
ON THAT AND BRING IT INTO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHICH I
THINK IS THE MUCH BETTER PROCESS.
ALONE WE'RE DEALING WITH THIS
IMPORTANT --
AND COMPLICATED --
POLICY I THINK IT'S GREAT THAT --
THE CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE THE
STRONGEST --
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS --
IN IN THE COUNTRY UP BUT I ALSO
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU --
FOR YOUR KNOWLEDGE MEN AND AND
YOU'RE KIND OF STATED
WILLINGNESS THAT YOU SAID HERE
TODAY TO KEEP ON WORKING ON THE
DETAILS --
BECAUSE THIS HAS BEEN YOU KNOW I
KNOW THAT A LOT OF FOLKS IN
WORKING ON THIS FOR A LONG TIME
BUT IN TERMS OF THE LANGUAGE IN
THIS BILL IT'S IT'S BEEN IN
PRINT FOR LESS THAN A WEEK --
WITH THE AMENDMENTS HAS BEEN
PARTLY FORTY EIGHT HOURS AND
WE'RE JUST HEARING FROM
INDUSTRIES THAT.
THAT THEY'RE WORRIED THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE IMPACTED AND
THEY'RE WORRIED THAT THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL DOESN'T
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS AND WE'RE
JUST BECOMING AWARE THAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME --
AND SO IS GOING TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO KEEP I LIKE THE
IDEA FROM THE NUMBER BAKER OF
MAYBE HAVING ANOTHER
INFORMATIONAL HEARING BEFORE THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE --
BUT MAKING SURE THAT WE CONTINUE
TO HEAR FROM INDUSTRIES --
EITHER ONES THAT WE KNEW ARE
GONNA BE IMPACTED ARE ONES THAT
WE YET DIDN'T REALIZE WE'RE
GONNA BE IMPACTED I WAS ALSO
VERY --
IMPRESSED NINE DUH OR IT WAS
VERY STRUCK BY THE NEWSPAPER
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CONCERNS THAT THEY HAD --
AND WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I
OFTENTIMES WE THINK WE'VE
ANTICIPATED ALL THE
UNANTICIPATED CONSEQUENCES BUT
WE HAVEN'T --
AND SO NOW THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS TO DIGEST
OF THE BILL THE THIRTY PAGES
THAT HE SAID MR ONE OBERNOLTE --
AND AND START TO CONSIDER HOW
THAT'S GOING TO IMPACT THEM
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT WERE REALLY
OPEN -- TO
IT THE HEARING FROM THEM IN
HEARING THE CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE AN IMPROVING THIS --
BEFORE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO DO THAT --
AND AND LOOK FOR THE WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR.
NOW ON THOSE ISSUES MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN.
LET ME ALSO I AT MY CONCERNS
AROUND THE NEWS GATHERING A
PIECE THAT.
WAS RAISED TODAY AND I THINK
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THERE WILL BE
SOME A CLEAN UP AND SOME OF
CONVERSATIONS AFTER THE FACT --
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE DAIS SEEING AND HEARING
[inaudible]
NINE MISTER CHAIR.
FROM THERE OR FROM HERE YOU MAY.
CLOSER HEARING OUT OF YOU HAVE
CONCLUDING COMMENTS I I LIKE TO
JUST TAKE A MINUTE TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AND I WANT TO THANK US.
ALL THAT THE SPIRIT ALL THE
OTHER WILL HARD WORK THAT
EVERYBODY HAS PUT AND AND IT'S
BEEN A TREMENDOUS STOP PROJECT
ALPHA ALL OF HIS IN.
A WE HAVE LEARNED FROM EACH
OTHER --
OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS A MONTH
COUPLE MONTHS AND IT'S BEEN A
VERY -- VERY --
GONE.
HA VERY THOUGHTS WHAT'S THE WORD
OTHER THAN STRESSFUL BUT ISRAEL
RADIO IT'S STILL.
THAT THAT TOO SO IT'S BEEN A
GREAT EXPERIENCE AND AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU ARE IN IN THE MONTHS THAT TO
COME SO WITHOUT THE I WANT.
TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THAT
TOMORROW PLEASE SO EVERYONE OF
YOU WHO CAN VOTE PLEASE VOTE OP
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A VERY SHORT
TIME WINDOW.
A TO GET THIS OVER TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE --
FOR WE WON'T GET TO ARE THE
SENATE WON'T GET TO VOTE ON IT
UNTIL AFTER TEN THIRTY WHAT
START DEBATE TEN FORTY SAY.
FORTY SEVEN THAT IS THE MAGIC
THING MAGICAL MOMENT SO ONCE
THEY ARE DONE DE NO POPULAR OVER
TO THE ASSEMBLY FOR US TO KIND
OF VOTE ON IT.
AND POLICE OF VOTE ARE AND END
OF IT SO SOME OF YOU LIKE TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF IT THAT WE
WELCOME THAT AS WELL.
OUGHT TO MOVED UP OFF OUR
FORWARD IN FASTER SALE.
SO WITHOUT I WANT TO THANK YOU
OUT SENATOR TO SENATORS WHICH
ELECTED MAKE IT ON MY
CLARIFICATION AND FORTY SEVEN
UNDER THE RULES.
APPROACH AND YOU KNOW THAT WE WE
HAVE BUT THAT'S A TIME WE CAN
TAKE IT UP SO WE COULD WE GET
SOME OTHER MATTERS AS WE ALL
KNOW WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH WE
COULD TAKE IT UP BEFORE THEN.
INCLUDE THE DEBATE AND THAT TEN
FORTY EIGHT I WOULD BE CAUTIOUS
THEN THE CALL THE ROLL AND THEN
BREAKS IT OVER TO YOUR HOUSE TO
GET IT MOVING AND THEN THEY HAVE
YOUR HEARING OFF THE FLOOR
QUICKLY FOR VOTE.
I BELIEVE OF APPROPRIATIONS IS A
GARCIA.
APPROPRIATIONS YES NO OKAY
TWENTY POINTED AND THEN GO THE
FLOOR AND GET OFF TO THE
GOVERNOR WHO GOES YEAR ONLY CAN
HAPPEN IMMEDIATELY SO WE CAN
CERTAINLY MEET THE DEADLINE IF
WE ALL LEFT.
DON'T TALK TOO MUCH THE IPHONE
STOP CLOCK WILL BE WILL BE OUT
SENATOR ANY FINAL YOU KNOW THE
FLOOR TOMORROW.
COULD ACTIVATE GOOD ALL THE ALL
THE SHORT I'D LIKE TO THANK GOD
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO AND CENTER
HERTZBERG MISTER MCTAGGART.
AND FRANKLY IF YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND THE MEMBERS FOR AYE --
YOUR WISDOM AND MANY COMMENTS
AND IN QUESTIONS HERE TODAY I
THINK THAT --
WILL BE WORKING HARD ON THIS
ISSUE -- ON
INTO THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
BIG THANK YOU TO THE STAFF FOR
THEIR TREMENDOUS WORK AND WITH
THAT WE ARE JOINED.
IF YOU'RE A VIDEO THAT BETTER
MANY DAVID I DON'T KNOW
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I THINK IT'S THANK
[inaudible]
BOB HERTZBERG [inaudible]
A ROBERT
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY